so we just showed his appearance in 2015
and here he is back on the rich eisen
show
show times black monday new air new
episodes air sunday nights showtime at
10 eastern time
with paul shearer how are you paul rich
i'm good i'm
very good it's very disconcerting to
hear and see yourself
before you come on if there's something
to put your me in my head that would be
it and
now i feel like i have to uh you know i
really got to step it up here
no paul your appearance in 2015 wasn't
that great so don't worry about it
there's no
is that better is that better for six
years
is that better oh man all right so uh
before we get into
uh black monday and then again uh your
pod and everything else that you're
doing
um this was um
a successful clipper season right i mean
this was a terrific
clipper season was it not yeah right i
mean look
i i'm very very happy overall uh
you know i think being a clippers fan is
a lot of disappointment
i think that since bombers come in
there's been steady moves forward every
single year
and even though last year was a real
bummer in the bubble
we needed that to get rid of doc to i
think really kind of
bring in this new this new season which
i think was
incredibly successful and fun all i
wanted as a fan was
fun games again and to to break the
curse of the western conference final so
i got that
yes everything else was house money i
know and then um but
and and it's just i mean it's crazy how
these things happened to have chris paul
be the one to end the run to go to the
nba finals
for him in his first it's it's weird man
is but also yes it's like it's it's i'll
say
uh i love the phoenix fans and and
everyone there
lovely and i feel like every every one
of these teams that was in the final
four
uh deserved it and and wanted it so bad
but
they had an easy run in there the sons i
mean we can't we can't uh argue that
they had a pretty smooth sailing i mean
every single team they faced was missing
their marquee player
are you putting an asterisk on their run
right now paul are you that guy
are you like i've seen the i've seen the
look like if you're there you're there
and if i was there i would be like who
cares about an asterisk
i don't care like i think it's for the
the non-fans to be judging the asterisk
right i'm but i'm not that i'm not that
person i'm just saying if i was a team
like that i would be psyched i wouldn't
be like
oh it's not great if clippers had a way
in where it was
a hundred percent i would take it i'm
just saying they had a pretty easy run
well you just went higher registering
right there paul you know you've got to
go higher educate a higher register
on the rich eisen show means you don't
really believe what you say you have to
go higher register to believe it
but but you know you didn't have the
jazz didn't have conley for
you know the full time and mitchell was
kind of hurt towards the end right i
mean
yeah i was saying this whole idea of
mitchell being hurt but mitchell was
putting up
30 points like he put up like five
30-point games it's like
i get that he's hurt but it was not
affecting his production on any level i
get that maybe he was missing a little
bit of speed but
you know it wasn't uh you know it wasn't
like a
it wasn't like oh wow he's really not a
scorer here where you like lose somebody
like kawhi
you know that's a big that's a big deal
all right well let's put all our cards
in the table
let's put all our cards to the table
right here is this you
maybe being a little bit what's the word
for it butt hurt in the fact that
chris paul gave a shout out to billy
crystal and not you
when he when he you know i saw this
shout out and by the way
billy crystal should be getting that
shout out although i did not see him at
a single playoff game
uh this entire run so right um he was
there that night
he was there he was yeah he was saying
hello tonight yeah he went to
all right i uh i i was looking out for
him a lot uh but no he should definitely
guess
look billy crystal is bowed down to him
he was there
through all of it uh a hundred percent
yeah uh you know
he he when lou gossett junior were
leaving the light on in the late 80s and
you'd like in the sports area
so they cleared the path for us did you
go to any of the games in phoenix did
you go to the games in fact yes
oh i went to game two in phoenix i was
there i was at a perfect vantage point
for that
insane final shot the valley oh you were
there
i traveled i bought tickets for game
seven in phoenix knowing that that was
probably
a reach but i was gonna you know i if we
were gonna go to a game seven i was
gonna do it and i've already said we
which is something i also hate no no but
i'm flogging myself
so uh paul shearer here on the rich
eisen show let's let's get into this
then
um where are you from originally are you
a los angeles guy or where are you from
no i'm a new york guy okay i grew up uh
with being like a knicks
uh yankees okay uh rangers
that and jets fan that was my kind of my
my calling card so when you moved to los
angeles you were that nick fan who said
there's no
chance on this green earth i'll become a
laker fan i'm choosing the clippers is
that your
i mean yeah i mean rich you got to talk
about it like this like i
i i was in a lot of hurt i mean nicks
and jets it was not it was not fun so
when i came to l.a i was like
i'm gonna have kids i'm gonna have a
family i'd love to bring them to games i
want them to have a team that they can
root for and they can see
i don't have my kids being like these uh
you know these fans of like the knicks
who come
like twice a year to play an afternoon
game and so
yeah it felt too bandwagon to me to jump
onto the lakers also
if i'm being very honest it was too
expensive uh
very good clippers tickets you could you
could go you could bring a couple people
right you could almost bring a family of
10 for 40 bucks at a certain point
you mean although a candy wasn't putting
fannies in the seats is that what you're
saying to me
[Laughter]
i think honestly you could you know
really uh they would they would give you
money to sit on the side
please probably we beg you to please
come no i remember seeing some of those
games in the old sports arena then they
of course did move to
staples and it did get a little bit you
know uh different i just
i just don't understand the laker fan
hate that was
palpable in this town watching the
clippers go on their run that was to me
unnecessary it really was you know um
yeah i don't know i mean you probably
have a better vantage point of where
that rivalry
it comes from and i've talked to so many
people and about it because of a lot of
laker fan friends and uh
that are not like that but well you
started it first the clipper started at
first it's like
well why it's like well because during
lob city uh
you were making fun of the lakers and we
weren't good and
you didn't respect us and then that's
one story and then another story is like
well those billboards
and it's like okay so there's a lot of
like like it just doesn't it just i
think it really just comes down to
at a certain point the clippers became
a little they just stopped sucking i
mean really that that seems to be
the the root of it it's uh on some level
there was
a little bit of competition they will
never usurp
the you know the 17 championships and
the legacy i mean i think the lakers are
synonymous with
like sports like them and the dallas
cowboys you can never you're never going
to take them down but it is
it was a pretty intense thing like going
to the stadium watching people in lakers
jerseys ready to boo
if the clippers lost like it was like it
was like just watching an executioner
do i get out of this alive or not and
then if we won
they would walk off and it was like okay
got out of that but there were some
there were some tougher nights leaving
there paul scheer here on the rich eisen
show let's talk some black monday on
showtime
10 eastern time um what what is it i
mean
what is it like playing somebody who has
an incredible time in the 1980s
you must be oh my gosh it's amazing
there's no
keto uh everyone's doing cocaine you
know uh
we can watch whatever we want to watch
you know it's a they
this show has been great to kind of live
through the 80s i didn't get a chance to
experience like being an adult in the
80s and
and now we're going into the 90s and man
it was it was a
while a way fun more fun time i mean
denim on top denim on bottom i mean
we're doing jay leno before jay leno
back then
oh my gosh it just seems like one of
those
shows where everyone seems to just have
a rip-roaring time that you get a script
and you're like i'm gonna dig into this
like with a knife and fork and just chew
it up you know
it's the best well you know it's
co-created by the guy uh david cast who
created happy endings who i know a lot
of people love happy endings and it's
got this cast that's
incredibly stellar from you know don
cheadle who is
just you know the gods he's got it all
going on he can do comedy drama whatever
and you got andrew reynolds and regina
hall and casey wilson
and myself plus you have all these great
people like ken marino
uh popping in it's just it's a stacked
cast
of the worst people in the world and
every season gets a little bit
you know more intense and weird this
season it's a whole murder mystery and
we're very much involved in the
televangelism world and the uh the world
of fashion so it's
it's been fun and um ken marino by the
way
greatest karaoke singer i've ever seen
in person in my entire life is macy gray
that will knock your socks off that's
true google ken marino
uh macy gray after you're done uh
watching the show today and and you'll
be
blown away and uh having been at a
karaoke uh
affair with ken marino uh if you have
one of those old karaoke machines
uh there is i forget what song it is now
that i'm bringing it up
but he is one of his first gigs in in
in the profession was i guess to dress
up as a cowboy and you know sometimes in
the
uh in the musical interlude moments an
old karaoke machines they'll have a
photograph on the screen one of them is
ken marino
and he's like by the way i'm in this a
karaoke song we're like what the hell
are you talking about and he points it
out it was
the whole room went insane like that
happened marino
is a full of hidden treasures uh for me
i'm a big disney fan
and when you go on the r uh the
aerosmith rock and roll roller coaster
he is the sound engineer in the pre-show
for that so when you are
getting ready to get on that roller
coaster this kim marino mixing at the
boards with the entire group of
aerosmith and ileana douglas
now i'm also going to ask a somewhat
personal question here paul but
it involves me so um so cause i can't
you can't help but notice your your
character um
in black monday um
has hair and um i don't know how long
have you been
married paul how long i've been married
i i'm like in my relationship with my
wife for 15 years i've been i think i'm
married for 10
or 11. okay i've been in a relationship
with i've known my wife since the
uh the mid 90s likes 96 97 we met at
espn uh so i've known her a long time i
would be genuinely concerned taking a
job
in which i put on hair because my i just
wouldn't want my wife to look at the
screen and give me the
huh you know she hates it my wife no
no she hates okay
now let's get in there she like she
doesn't like it here's the thing you are
a good-looking bald man
and don't let anyone ever tell you
different god bless you
some people can wear it and some people
can't right i think you can
okay uh very well thank you um
and i'll tell you this this is how i
know my wife is being serious because
and this is some hollywood whatever but
her person on grayson frankie who does
hair
very well you know established great
person
very very smart has an in with a person
who can
could do like if i wanted hair i could
go to his guy and i could get here i'm
like i'm impossible to get here because
i'm too bald i'm too far gone
but not anymore right new technology
things are happening right
and i said to my wife and i was like
what do you would you ever want that and
she was like
never absolutely not and i feel like
i don't know i feel like i've talked to
a few people about it and not that i
want to do it but people are like
that's you yet you've got to embrace you
so i i feel like
i like wearing the hair for characters
and stuff like that but it's not me
so when so when the hair comes off after
a long day of shooting black monday
you're like you're like relieved right
because i got to be honest with you
there
uh when i shot i i i did the uh
for the our show open for the super bowl
a couple of years ago in miami i got
into a wig
because we did a csi miami spoof and i
did the whole dave
david caruso thing and my susie my wife
saw and she i got the huh like that
i got that i got that no that's why i
was kind of asking you about it
like huh and i did at one point look at
the you know
me with the wig and it looked really
real and i thought to my i i even gave
myself that so you
i god bless you paul god bless you i get
i get i get a moment i
i get that when you glance at yourself
in the mirror you're like oh it looks a
little bit different but here's the
other thing i'm going to say about
i can i could talk about bald all the
time okay uh but
uh i'll tell you but i think this much
when you are bald and you have been bald
for a while yes
um you don't age right and most people
with hair
age a little bit different like so you
will stay when
you might have aged quicker but you
won't age
like you but you'll stay at this spot
bald doesn't get like larry david looks
the same age
his whole life right like you know so
it's like you know uh
so i feel like the the hair is a tricky
thing so we
we get it on the other side we may have
gotten there got a little bit older
quicker
but there we go so it's literally and
figuratively a back end deal
paul is what you're saying that that is
it i mean that's i'm gonna say i feel
like
you know like i feel like i've looked
roughly the same
for at least 20 years you looked
50 when you were 12. pretty much exactly
by the way
it wasn't a good look when i was 20
years old but now i'm accustomed to it
now i feel good about it
and your wife is says keep it okay look
at
you look at us that's what i'm saying
look at the brotherhood
paul scheer part of the brotherhood he's
not going to turn his back on us like
dion or brian erlacker yeah you know
like all of a sudden you thought you
knew somebody and then you don't anymore
you know jason alexander with his hair
system
uh i the bit i did on curb with larry
was like
it was uh i was his nemesis in one thing
and one of the things that was most
upsetting to him is that i was a a bald
man like a bald man being
uh a nemesis to another bald man he felt
like that really crossed the line
you gotta stick together you gotta stick
together stick together
oh my gosh uh well paul thanks for the
time man let's do this again um
you know we're fully vaxxed you want to
come in and hang with us let's go do it
let's do it we'll do thanks bud you got
it that's paul scheer
new episodes of black monday aaron
sunday on show time at 10 eastern time
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here